hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast just checking in on you I just
realized why am i checking in on you I
mean I used to check in on you just to
see how your work week was going you
know I pop in how's it going how's old
[ __ ] you know that chatty [ __ ]
chick down the way and everybody's
[ __ ] business did you have to go to
[ __ ] age you know I check in on you I
see how you were doing but you know what
you're living my life now you're home
you ain't working right you know all of
us [ __ ] douchebags and show business
we don't [ __ ] work right yeah we just
[ __ ] sit around and then we make your
videos telling you how you can be better
people right yeah that's right you know
why I love the Internet I don't give a
[ __ ] what your messages I don't give a
[ __ ] what you say you are gonna get a
[ __ ] thrashing hey everybody I take
responsibility for my part and polluting
the oceans and I will try to consume
less and recycle [ __ ] he's against
pollution
listen we've all been cooped up now
we've been cooped up for a while you
know when some of us are stronger than
others and can handle this [ __ ] other
people cannot other people what do they
do what do they do they gotta stick
their head out of the rabbit hole nice
going everybody everybody we had to walk
around and be like this virus thing is
designed to take down Trump everybody
saying Trump came up with the [ __ ]
thing you know do you ever think that
there's just seven billion [ __ ] on the
planet and eventually someone was going
to eat something or [ __ ] something and
sneeze on somebody we all knew this was
coming how the [ __ ] you can politicize a
goddamn disease is [ __ ] beyond me and
if you really think that it came from
the the red of the blue side I got to
tell you if this if this is that this is
what you guys are saying it some of you
guys are saying if you if this is what
this is did this do this this wouldn't
come from Democrats or Republicans it'd
come above that above that whatever's
above that like beyond oil companies I I
would never say beyond banks okay
because that is the top of the food
chain
okay everybody they always say is you
become successful tell you right now the
higher up you go there's still gonna be
a dick in your ass because this there's
still somebody above you there's always
going to be some but there there is
there is a level you know when you go on
that journey of power and you just you
just keep trying to get up what is the
level or I don't have a dick in my ass
you know at what point is my money
coming straight to me and it doesn't go
through nine other [ __ ] people and
then I get paid with the check with that
person's name on it rather than the
person that the money initially came
when does that happen
and I'll tell you when that happens when
you reach the level where you decide all
right
we need to do something about the world
population in my hand I have a virus in
my other hand I have the cure I am going
to release this but not before everyone
at this table
it gets inoculated I want you to all see
if I want you to trust me
everybody sits back right they [ __ ]
get inoculate is it the right [ __ ]
word I don't know I'm not at that table
and then that's it does everybody feel
fine everybody has the antibodies
wonderful and then they just take the
little glass thing off the birds are
away it's not coming from the president
all right and it's not aimed at the
president the president I've said for
years you know the president is the
president is basically that person when
your flights delayed you know that poor
person has to stand behind the counter
and get yelled at that's what the
president is you know it's not the guy
who owns the [ __ ] airline it's the
person where in the airline's [ __ ]
uniform and then you get to yell at that
person and take out your childhood on
them and [ __ ] [ __ ] moan and complain
and all of that [ __ ] [ __ ] because
evidently you wanted to roll the dice
with 300 other people's lives because
you wanted to make sure you got the
Wichita on time so you could get there
for the [ __ ] I don't know the bake
sale whatever the [ __ ] he wanted to do
you know I've been guilty of that [ __ ]
when they delay a flight you [ __ ] I
always think it's a conspiracy I know
what's going on here the [ __ ] plane
was only half full and you weren't gonna
eat it so now you gonna say there's a
[ __ ] light out and yadda yadda yadda
and we're gonna [ __ ] I'm not saying
they don't do that [ __ ] alright I
remember a long time ago when I worked a
cruise ship the one and only time I ever
worked a cruise ship and I'll tell you
it was sweet money I took the gig I the
lady the leg literally called me and
said hey we you know a friend of yours
does these cruise ships and he
recommends you and I said that's amazing
you know my head I'm like I need this
money but ice ice I [ __ ] told them I
[ __ ] told them I said I'm not sure I
have a cruise ship
act and they said to me no no no this is
this is the young [ __ ] cool crowd you
know all those all those [ __ ] kids
doing the method and the [ __ ] moly
whatever that drugs are in this janitor
they love taking [ __ ] cruises I'm
thinking like they like doing it yeah
yeah they [ __ ] love it right so you
know probably if I if I really thought
about it I knew it was a lie but I
needed the money I needed the money man
right I mean look at you man my [ __ ]
legs don't work man so I was just like
[ __ ] I'm gonna do it okay so I take
the [ __ ] gig and of course it's a
bunch of [ __ ] old people and of
course I ate my balls and of course the
captain wrote a letter to the agency and
I never [ __ ] worked again in the crew
he actually did me a favor because when
I did this cruise ship this was at least
it was about 18 years I didn't borrow
2002 it was [ __ ] like 18 years ago
Jesus Christ and I was bombing so bad I
was just trying to make the band laugh
behind the curtain so once you start
playing in the band you know it's it's
it's a rap okay the gigs over and all
that type of [ __ ] I remember the guys
smiley guy who was [ __ ] hosting the
thing was going like hey you know
afterwards it was like this [ __ ]
dinner or some [ __ ] and all the acts me
the juggler I swear to God the juggler
whose [ __ ] joints were all blown out
from juggling and I remember he was he
was he had this big [ __ ] book on real
estate he was getting his real estate
license and I was just going like I have
never been further away from the
Hollywood dream than I am right now
I am out in the middle of the [ __ ]
ocean all right it was really the Gulf
of Mexico but it felt like the ocean to
me all right I don't know I understand
how that's not a [ __ ] ocean okay cuz
from space I can see that it's
surrounded by land that's the [ __ ]
ocean
alright the goddamn Lake Michigan the
second you can't see [ __ ] Michigan
anymore you're in the ocean alright I
don't mind a lake because there's no
shacks in there alright
but I am vain enough to be annoyed with
the fact that if I go under in a lake
they're never gonna find my body
alright because the water is never cold
enough for whatever the [ __ ] happens
in your gut after you died to make you
to make you a [ __ ] fool right you're
going under and that's it that is
[ __ ] it and they're never gonna see
you again so yeah I was like I've never
been further away from my dream of
somehow getting in at the Comedy Store
and being in movies and [ __ ] whatever
the [ __ ] I wanted I didn't remember what
I didn't remember I wanted to do selling
out clubs or some [ __ ] so these guys
were all getting like their [ __ ] real
estate licenses right or at least that
one guy was so the guys smiley guy I
swear I know I've told this story before
at some point I must have told a story I
mean this is how old the crowd was he
was coming out and he was starting the
show he's like bands playing his [ __ ]
and he's like all right everybody goes
if you happy and you know it clap your
hands and they did and that's when I
start that's when the beads of sweat
started forming on my forehead going
like this is this is not and now I'm
gonna get [ __ ] bagged I'm gonna get
[ __ ] yelled at and all of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I told it I I don't
think I'm the guy for this [ __ ] gig
so whatever I get out there I'm doing my
shanae's anybody seen the movie Titanic
nothing in the crowd so you know as a
joke I go ahead let me rephrase that how
many you people were on the Titanic uh
you know they [ __ ] you know dentures
falling out and [ __ ] right I'll tell you
it kills me that was 17 years ago and
now I look at those people and now I'm
about probably yeah about 13 years
younger than the oldest person in the
[ __ ] crowd and that's how quick it
goes so my balls all [ __ ] week what
is this getting to I'm getting to the
correlation between what the airline's
do sometimes not all the time most times
I think they're trying to save your life
and then all the times you know Jeff
feels expensive so they're gonna say
yeah you know
smells like [ __ ] too much in the aft
bathroom you know they throw in one of
those [ __ ] aviation terms asked you
know inside the cabin expedite you know
I even think that's a [ __ ] word I
think they just gave that word for
[ __ ] stewardesses so they could sound
like they're running [ __ ] post-911 they
never tried to expedite the boarding
process they were too busy trying to get
your shit-faced why do I have this loud
leather couch I don't know I don't know
why it makes me feel like a man okay so
anyway I hate my boss and then I sort of
figured out what I had to do the little
song-and-dance I could do you know I was
[ __ ] going back to some clean ease
that I had or whatever and I got myself
through it this guy go you gotta meet
all these [ __ ] people well you know
these are the bigwigs they're on the
ship who [ __ ] booked all the ships
and I'm thinking like dude I don't want
to get a real estate license okay I want
to get on [ __ ] TV and by the way
there was no internet connection no cell
phone no [ __ ] nothing you went out to
sea and your loved ones did not hear
about you they'd watch the news every
night to see if the [ __ ] ship went
under right and when it what didn't make
news it like well I mean I guess it
didn't sink or they were in the process
of process of it right now when they're
going through they've probably seen
their first shark at this point I'm
hoping the hypothermia kicks in and
numbs them from the neck down before
that thing comes up and takes a what are
they what do they call that thing that
the the test bite little you know hey
try a little a little tapas see what
that tastes like
yeah it's kind of edible you know that's
when you want to be near a fatty
somebody nice and [ __ ] marbled right
like a [ __ ] cowboy steak but anyway I
learned on that thing the musicians on
there told me one time they were on a
they were on a cruise ship and they got
two giant [ __ ] engines right and one
of them [ __ ] crapped out so obviously
they could only go half as fast so they
weren't going to be able to make all
three stops on the [ __ ]
on the toilet little cruise right so
what they said cuz they didn't want to
own up to it because then they'd have to
owe money what they said was that there
was a [ __ ] hurricane and uh what's
one of those [ __ ] what's that city
all the [ __ ] used to go to down in
Mexico you know come back with the
[ __ ] hair braided all the white
chicks would come back you know Balu
somebody in a [ __ ] cartel whatever
the [ __ ] they did down there I I never
understood it right they [ __ ] go down
there right and uh the [ __ ] was it
called it was one of those places
everybody goes to I'm too pasty to know
the names of these it wasn't Acapulco
that's Versys [ __ ] reference was one
of my favorite things he ever said
Acapulco he talked about it like it was
still the place to go to let me see here
it began with a [ __ ] a it's like a
[ __ ] destination people go there all
I know is Cabo Wabo [ __ ] the red
rockers place there Sammy Hagar I forget
it was one of these [ __ ] places that
people want to go to who's sort of the
jewel on the unab on the beautiful place
right was Cozumel New Orleans and then
they were supposed to go whale oh not
well that's not a rubra yeah I don't
give a [ __ ] it was some [ __ ] gorgeous
place in Mexico right they said that
there was a [ __ ] hurricane and that
there's no internet there's no cell
service nobody you know can fact check
this [ __ ] it's a long story short
somebody has some sort of medical
episode alright and the nearest port is
the port where they said that there was
a [ __ ] hurricane so they ended up
having to go there and they pulled in
and it was a bright sunny [ __ ] day
and there's like five other cruise ships
already there and they totally got
busted and everybody get [ __ ] pissed
and then I think they just gave up free
hot fudge sundaes to those fat [ __ ] and
everybody went into a diabetic coma and
by the time they got to Cozumel they
couldn't even remember anymore
something like that as telling that
story I'm like well why would they just
fly a [ __ ] helicopter out there
I don't know I don't know but that was
the story that was told to me so I don't
I don't know if that makes any [ __ ]
sense
speaking of which me being on the wrong
gigs I've been cleaning up my office
here going through all kinds of [ __ ]
actually taking out photos that I took
years and years ago when you used to
have the disposable cameras and and I
got like photo albums and I'm trying to
put them all away and everything and
I've just come across some [ __ ] that I
have not seen in [ __ ] like two
decades and one of the things I actually
posted it I'm reaching it forward here I
posted it on my Instagram you know not
really thinking because the woman's full
name was on it and I want to clear her
name here I I was doing this gig I'm not
even gonna say where I should have
blocked out her last name I wasn't
[ __ ] thinking I just it just struck
me as so funny and I've literally
remembered when somebody handed me this
[ __ ] note oh my god the name of the
college is on the back of this [ __ ]
thing are you [ __ ] that's where I was
holy [ __ ] I thought it was I was in
Colorado how they all run together so
anyway I had to do a nooner now a nooner
if you're new to this podcast is
literally it's a college show it's just
a stand-up show in the middle of the day
it's not necessarily at 12 noon it's
usually around one o'clock and at
colleges that means you're going to be
performing in a cafeteria if you're
lucky a room off of a cafeteria and
you're gonna come in and do a late-night
set in the middle of these [ __ ] 18 to
22 year old kids trying to eat grilled
cheese sandwiches you know write a paper
or whatever the [ __ ] they're doing they
are they are hell gigs and I used to
have to play like a game mentally I
would have to go somewhere mentally when
I went I would immediately walk in and I
would just think in an hour I'm gonna
have my check and I'll be in my car and
I'm gonna leave and no matter how
[ __ ] humiliating this is I'm never
gonna see these [ __ ] people again and
I'm gonna have my 700 bucks
which was
huge before taxes of course but by the
end all the [ __ ] in the travel and
everything was probably like you know
175 bucks but what you do is if you had
another gig later on that night okay
then you were doubling up so you took
the [ __ ] humiliation because you
needed the [ __ ] money right and after
every I would say 99% of my nooner gigs
as I was driving away I was already on
my flip phone late 90s early 2000 cell
phone calling my agent and I was saying
dude I'm never [ __ ] doing one of
those again that was most [ __ ]
humiliating and they would sit there
going up yep okay okay I get it I get it
I mean it's up to you it's up to you
right and then like a week later he'd be
booking me on some more and be like now
listen I know I know you said that you
didn't want to do nooners but it's my
job to bring you all offers okay you're
making this amount of money but I can
add $700 for which will pay for your
flight know your travel above a night of
you know I just [ __ ] this booked me
booked me before I say no right then he
would book me and then I would go up and
I would eat my balls and I would and it
was just be like you know and then I
would pitch him out now that was that
was how it went that was how it went
okay and as much as I'm silent like the
[ __ ] in that story the agent knew
that it was part of him getting the
Commission that you know I if I was
gonna go up to and humiliate himself
myself he was gonna have to listen to me
[ __ ] [ __ ] moan and complain about it
he got his money I got my money and then
we've been it like whenever we would
hang out we would just laugh about it so
anyway so I met this [ __ ] college
that I thought was in Colorado and the
only reason why I'm not telling you the
name cuz the name of the ladies out
there and I feel really bad about it but
I already posted the [ __ ] thing on
Instagram so I go up to do this [ __ ]
nooner alright and I went up there guns
a-blazing it was a packed [ __ ] house
of people walking around with no [ __ ]
clue that there's gonna be a show I get
the typical [ __ ] intro where it's
just somebody saw sparkling
vh1 I love the eighties
please welcome bill burr and then I wish
had to [ __ ] walk out and then do they
hey what the [ __ ] is going on and you
would literally do three jokes before
they even understood what was going on
and then of course there'd be the class
clowns and I was immediately the
substitute teacher and then they'd get
going and then I would have to shut them
the [ __ ] up while for the most part
working clean alright so I really had to
go hard with what they look looked like
you know and I don't give a [ __ ] big
nose fat ass I don't give a [ __ ] what it
was I was going right for the jugular
because I still had another [ __ ] 57
minutes so anyways I go up there and you
know in defense of the school I was
judging this gig by all my other nooners
because occasionally that was a good
nooner and I went up there with a chip
on both [ __ ] shoulders and just
started a Visser ating everything afraid
to even pause because I didn't want to
hear the lack of laughter and I was just
like an auctioneer up there blowing
through my act and [ __ ] on
everything the state the school anything
that I could [ __ ] anything that would
get me to not stop talking and the funny
thing to me my delusion Minh I actually
thought I was doing all right and all I
remember there was there was this guy we
was he was walking up he was walking by
you know you know cafeteria they had the
ceiling to floor of glass windows and
this guy came walking by and he had on
the sky-blue [ __ ] three-piece suit but
he also had on a cowboy hat and these
brown boots you know looking like jr.
Ewing so I just I mean I go look at this
guy out here Jesus Christ he looks he
looks like he's going to get it he looks
like he's trying to get a loan for a
horse is what I said right which I
thought was a decent joke got nothing
right and I'm plowing ahead and all of a
sudden this this kid came walking up and
it might have been the lady who handed
it to me and just handed me I was about
12 minutes in and it said can you wrap
it up in five minutes
[Music]
it's just like I had mixed emotions
because I was in what half of me was
like lady I'll wrap this up in [ __ ]
four minutes I don't give a [ __ ] but
then I was thinking like oh I'm
contractually obligated to do an hour if
I don't do an hour I'm not getting paid
but I knew it was going bad enough that
she was literally in the nicest way ever
you know giving me the hook like
Showtime at the Apollo the Sandman came
out this is the white version it's very
nice capitalized dashes the whole
[ __ ] thing she let me get out of
there respectfully rather than making me
take the beating I deserve so I wrapped
it up I'd you guys been great thank you
and I got off and then she actually
apologized to me and said sorry this was
a bad idea
blah blah blah and she gave me my check
and everything I ended up apologizing
bad cuz she was soda if she just read me
the riot act and kept the money or he
did you [ __ ] check you godless New
York liberal whatever she would have
thought of me back then and but she
didn't she actually gave me the check so
if anybody looks at that it is funny to
get I mean I've never gotten that ever I
only got it once in 28 [ __ ] years can
you wrap it up five minutes
so anyway anybody who's looking at
please don't [ __ ] on her I feel bad that
her name is out there I'm not gonna say
what state I'm sure she's moved on is
very soon but she was a sweetheart about
it and I had way worse I had way I mean
I remember that time I worked the
religious place one of those Christian
colleges and they said work clean and to
me clean was don't say [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know so I was filling in the F words
by taking the Lord's name in vain not
thinking that this was a Catholic school
cuz that's how every time Jesus Christ
with you know I guess they'd be what the
[ __ ] you doing but I was saying you know
blah blah blah love for Christ's sake
you know was doing like Dennis mill for
Christ's sake what the [ __ ] quit
quake right and I got off state orally
[ __ ] you know
reamed out for that [ __ ] balled out
whatever I used to used to say his kids
when I was a kid so anyway I just struck
me as funny and had I actually been
thinking
people would enjoy seeing that and think
it was funny but I wasn't thinking that
a [ __ ] name was on there and I hate
doing that to somebody so my apologies
to her she was a [ __ ] sweetheart and
she paid me so and apologize for the
situation she put me in and by the end I
was apologized and I felt like given
half the [ __ ] money back but I didn't
you know I got into my [ __ ] you know
Chevy Cavalier whatever I rented from
[ __ ] national at that foot can point
my life
so anyway anyway let's do a little bit
of reads here for the week
oh look CBD MD you know by the way I
took some of this [ __ ] the other night
beautiful beautiful as a leader in the
CBD industry CBD MD is committed MD Mike
delta CBD Mike Delta Charlie Bravo Delta
Mike Delta is committed to providing you
with high quality THC free CBD oil
products alright this is all aboveboard
whether you not follow you hey man like
I was just like tripping man this ain't
for you
CBD THC free tango hotel Charlie free
Charlie Bravo Delta oil products whether
you're gunning for a raise or an Olympic
gold medal you need to stay at the top
of your game everyone from weekend
warriors to pros like Bubba Watson Steve
Smith senior and home
mas Fidel trusts CB DMV to give them the
natural support and relief they need to
reach their goals and with so many
world-class professional athletes
turning to CB DMD you can be sure you're
getting a safe clean product from
tinctures I already looked this up I
don't know how to say that to topicals
two bath bombs which others and even pet
products I could have used that for my
[ __ ] pit bull years ago not saying
that that will stop him from eating your
neighbor all right
let's clarify that they've got something
for everyone talk about your personal
experience with it well I tried it the
other night and I [ __ ] fell great and
I woke up I best eight hours sleep I've
gotten a long time to make it easy to
discover the potential of CBD for
yourself
CBD MD is offering my listeners 20% off
your purchase when you use the promo
code birbee u RR @ CB d md comm once
again that CBD md comm promo code bar
for 20% off your order or premium CBD
oil products from CBD MD alright
indogene you know they're back you know
having clothes that fit just right can
be a huge confidence booster especially
you know you want a pair of slacks that
really complements you've already
described any particular issues you had
you've often run into when shopping for
clothing all right I'll let you guys
know on something I haven't told
everybody before I am a big fan of the
male thong okay and one of the problems
I have had is it's great up until about
lunchtime and then afterwards the
chafing sets in and it really affects my
mood and my attitude around work okay
talk about how you feel when you find
that rare piece of clothing that fits
you just right when I finally found a
male silky-smooth song I mean my ass was
happy and then my mic she was happy
indogene O Indochina was started on the
belief that
custom clothing shouldn't cost a fortune
describe how wearing your custom piece I
think I already did that motivate your
audience you guys with endo Chi dope you
can get made-to-measure
clothing at fair prices including suits
blazes shirts and coats yeah if you can
get a custom suit at a fair price I mean
this sells itself people don't need to
know about my undergarments there you
get to customize everything from the
fabric and the lining to the lapel shape
and monogram the choice is all yoas the
best part Indochina
Chino suits start at just 299 bucks all
customizations included Indo Chino has
showrooms across North America or you
can book a virtual appointment
especially now the Cova this is perfect
and shop online at IND Oh ch Ino
Indochina dot-com Chino comm and right
now you can get an extra $30 off any
purchase of $399 or more 399 or more at
Indo Chino calm when entering BRR at
checkout that's Indo Chino calm promo
code BRR Bravo uniform Romeo Romeo
all right stamps calm we're all doing
our best to stay safe and healthy right
now but what if you need to go to the
post office
what if you need postage to send out and
packages listen you've heard me talk
about stamps calm they've been
sponsoring this show for well over seven
years now if you haven't tried it what
the [ __ ] are you waiting for huh I mean
Plus stamps calm is completely online
which saves you time no more
inconvenient trips to the post office
stamps calm brings all the services of
the US Postal Service right to your
computer and the safety and comfort of
your own home office or anywhere else
you are hunkering down right now whether
you're a small business sending invoices
an online seller shipping out products
Oh
or you just work from home and need to
mail stuff stamps.com can handle it all
with ease simply use your computer to
print US postage 24/7 for any letter any
package any class of mail anywhere you
want to send once your mail is ready
just leave it for your mail carrier
schedule a free package pickup or drop
it in a mailbox no human contact
required in that it's that simple and
like I said with stamps calm you can get
great discounts to five cents off every
first-class stamp and up 62 percent off
UPS USPS sorry not us UPS USPS United
States Postal Service shipping rates
stamps calm is a no-brainer especially
now saving you time and money and
keeping you safe in these crazy times
right now my listeners get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitment just go
to stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in BER
bu RR that stamps.com enter ber stay
safe my France
alright so guess what everybody that
troubadour show as promised is going
down this Saturday I'm gonna record
there will be no crowd there is no
tickets for this I will be recording I'm
sorry maybe Sunday I think it's Sunday
not Saturday Sunday I will be recording
at the truth all proceeds from the show
there'll be a donation button donate
anything you can the Troubadour is one
of the most legendary live music venues
in this country they're going through a
tough time there's all this bad stuff
all this negative stuff about people
doing stuff to other people all the
[ __ ] you know race stuff all of this
[ __ ] that's going on it's just a really
you know a lot of news that just makes
you just not like people you know what I
mean just how can human beings treat
other human beings this way there's a
lot of that [ __ ] going out there so this
is something positive that I'm trying to
do in the middle of this thing I promise
I will make a black-and-white video
talking about what a wonderful person I
am beforehand oh my god I should do that
but anyways we're gonna videotape it I'm
gonna have autographed posters that you
by all of it other than the shipping
costs out to you guys I'm anything I'm
gonna use stamps condescended out all of
that [ __ ] is going to go to the
Troubadour and if it goes well and i'm
able to raise them some money which i
really hope so someday when you guys can
come to LA you can see the next great
band there or one of your favorite bands
I mean everybody from like I mean you
Jackson Browne Guns and Roses Richard
Pryor Steve Martin all of these people
that I love they have all played they're
all broke out of that place
or whatever it just worked on getting
better in that place it's gonna be an
absolute honor to perform there and like
I said anything anything that you can
donate I know everybody is going through
a difficult time here so I know that
this is a big ass but you know if this
goes well I'm gonna probably be just
once a month to help them get through
this [ __ ] and then like I said when the
second we can [ __ ] polka heads out of
the rabbit hole and it's safe I plan on
doing a runner shows down there
in front of you great people and at that
great venue and I just make sure that
that place doesn't go away because I
know that people are losing their
favorite diners and [ __ ] like that
anything you know you know something
positive okay there you go
and with that that is the that is the
podcast I watched some I watched one
movie this week I watched the five
Bloods the new spike Lee movie or joint
as he says Delroy Lindo absolutely
killed it some of my favorite [ __ ]
actors are in it check that out if you
get a chance and I went back to oath
just absolutely phenomenal show I don't
know why I stopped watch it I got busy
and then I you know I literally get
overwhelmed when I get like behind in
shows sometimes so this now I finally at
the time because people tell you this
right now and if you hear the excitement
in my voice it is because I am excited
my office is almost finally [ __ ]
cleaned alright and when this thing is
[ __ ] clean I cleaned this out I
cleaned out my [ __ ] garage I cleaned
out my [ __ ] drum room
my walk-in closet is clay of everything
my bedside table I got nothing left to
do all my football cards are going to be
in albums all of my photos are gonna be
in albums everything's gonna be where I
know it's supposed to be and then I'm
gonna have nothing but free time and I
mean I got it I need a TV show I mean
other than the fact that I got a newborn
and a three and a half year old but you
know when they're both napping you know
I could sneak off watch an episode I
could go play some [ __ ] drums i whole
world's [ __ ] wide open for me I'm
back off the sugar everybody I'm off the
sugar but I'm back on cigars I have two
cigars left I'm gonna smoke both of
those this month and then I'm back on
the [ __ ] wagon because you know what
I don't have any more cigars
in my little humidor there and then I'll
just you know that's it
okay I saw some bad news today just [ __ ]
bums me out I just don't like seeing all
this [ __ ] negativity it's why I don't
try to watch the news I [ __ ] hate
watching it so I was stressed out and I
grabbed a nice ice-cold [ __ ] root
beer and a nice tasty cigar and I got to
admit I [ __ ] enjoyed the [ __ ] out of
it I really did I really did but you
know I got two little ones and I got to
stay alive so I can't [ __ ] do it but
I got two more and I'm definitely gonna
[ __ ] smoke them this month that's it
and then I'm [ __ ] I'm back on the
[ __ ] wagon alright and I'm saying
that out loud so if I don't then you
guys will give me [ __ ] and then I'll get
me back on right that's how I'm hoping
it's gonna work alright so please
everybody next Monday I believe we'll
have I don't know they have to edit it I
don't know how it's gonna work when the
Troubadour short show is gonna come out
but I am so [ __ ] excited to get back
on stage even though there's gonna be
nobody there and I'm interested to see
what its gonna bring out of me all of
this [ __ ] that I've been sitting on for
the last four months so I'm hoping it's
gonna be a [ __ ] good show other than
that it's gonna it's you know it's just
a great [ __ ] cause all right that's
it all right god bless you you [ __ ]
have a wonderful [ __ ] weekend and I
will talk to
on Monday hey what's going on it's bill
burr and it's the Monday morning podcast
from Monday June 25th could you hear me
looking for the date there I kind of
like was looking and I June 25th June
25th sorry I'm actually excited cuz I'm
doing a Sunday night so this [ __ ]
thing is gonna be up midnight West Coast
time in the continental United States
which means I don't have to deal with
anybody you know giving me [ __ ] dude
what the [ __ ] you know what what the
[ __ ] right back at you I'm in a great
goddamn move my lady you have left this
state and I am all alone now and I'm
remembering what it was like man I just
made my freckled ass some [ __ ]
chicken I had boneless i debone those
thighs too like a muhfucka I'm such a
stupid move I had I had boneless chicken
breasts no boneless chicken thighs and
brought broccoli I can't say that word
without I can't say broccoli without an
Asian accent I don't know why I know why
cuz when I lived in New York City and I
was broke there was a Chinese restaurant
around the corner and I always ordered
chicken and broccoli okay if I wasn't
eating sketti with [ __ ] prego I would
call up and once while I would treat
myself with a little Chinese food and I
would call up they like hello
number one I'm like a number one what's
up can I get uh can I get chicken and
broccoli they made chicken broccoli
whatever since then I've said that so
just in case you thought I had any
Chinese blood in me I don't I consider
those people my friends for all the
chicken and
Guri they made me back in the late 90s
this sounds like an apology like a
corporate apology
I had no dealings with number one
Chinese food I I did stop in there on a
number of occasions I did partake in
some of the cuisine that was offered but
at no time was there any inappropriate
touching
underneath that filthy [ __ ] glass
that I don't think was bulletproof you
know I'll tell you the Chinese
restaurants in [ __ ] New York where I
lived anyways when I was on the Upper
East Side Jesus Christ you know and I
mean it was like you have some either it
was either rusty rusty great between you
and the other person or just filthy
glass plastic or some [ __ ] I don't know
why don't
oh Christ don't even or I'm saying look
at my dog just [ __ ] lay in there can
you can you get a goddamn job and come
you know contribute I'm actually jealous
thanks [ __ ] skinny as hell dude but
dogs emaciated dropped her off but the
trainer I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened now well what were you doing
over there alright let's let's get the
podcast let's get it let's let's get it
back under control I didn't do [ __ ]
today so anyway so my woman's out of
town
my lady she's out of town so uh you know
what's funny is she keeps checking in on
me you know what are you doing what's
going on you know and you know what it
is it's one because she misses me in -
because they think that we're [ __ ]
morons and she just wants to hear like
how what a difficult time I'm having
without her you know like I don't even
know how to make cereal like like I'm
some sitcom [ __ ] guy all right it's
not how it's going down I did the
[ __ ] laundry I made myself a healthy
dinner a protein no bigger than the size
of my head is now how we supposed to eat
and in some fun a vegetable all right go
[ __ ] yourself you know what I had a
great time doing it I haven't cooked in
years and you know why because my woman
is oppressive in the kitchen
she loves cooking so anytime I go to
cook she comes in there she's looking
over my [ __ ] shoulder just why are
you cutting them up that way [ __ ] try
to make you a goddamn meals one of the
nicest things somebody can do for you
prepare a meal for you just sit there
shut the [ __ ] up and let me do you think
what do you think I did eight out of
eight out of goddamn garbage kids before
I met you
she was gives me [ __ ] about the way I
make my eggs because she you know she
always says I always do whenever I make
scrambled eggs or whatever like there's
too much egg gets stuck to the [ __ ]
pan and it's a pain in the ass to watch
to wash I mean you know it's like I'm
sorry I don't spray it with you know
[ __ ] the ozone layer Pam at every
goddamn time dripping with the [ __ ] no
wonder it doesn't stick I'm surprised it
doesn't [ __ ] slide right off under
the floor this is you know what this is
what this is you just listen to a
pathetic man who's psyched that he's
finally in his place by himself and he
can just deliver his entire argument
without being interrupted so uh I'm
telling you she wants to come back and
as much as she wants the place to be
neat she wants it to be a [ __ ]
disaster she wants to feel needed she
wants to feel that I am [ __ ] lost
without her and I'm such a [ __ ] I am NOT
gonna let that happen this place is
gonna be spotless it's gonna be ready
for one of those movie drill sergeants
you know those guys that get in your
face you know you can come over here and
bounce a [ __ ] quarter right off my
goddamn face every whatever the [ __ ]
they do off the beds
she's very thing I would never make it
in the military I'm supposed to be able
to bounce a foot in court why why are
you supposed to be able to bounce a
quarter why does that somehow make me
you know better at fighting the enemy if
I can throw dirty change at a blanket
and then and then catch it like the Fonz
you know what happened to you sir what
did you really want to do you know did
you really want to do this and scream at
P that was your that was your dream to
scream at people for your entire [ __ ]
life that's what you wanted to do
with that Hitler fade do you know Hitler
had like a Fresh Prince from Bellaire
haircut mixed with a Martin Sheen in
Apocalypse
he was Martin Sheen Apocalypse Now on
top but he had like he had a fade down
below that that Will Smith's character
with the eight-ball leather jacket what
I would have loved he would have loved
it I'm sorry I've been watching a lot of
[ __ ] about [ __ ] mass murderers lately
and he always comes up of course you
know what I mean can't have a think
about mass murders without Hitler right
I can't [ __ ] do it can't have a rock
show without Zeppelin man stairway to
heaven you know that's what it is you
got a [ __ ] ham that [ __ ] in there so
um so that's my goal that's my goal and
I'm actually wrestling with this should
I leave the place a little bit dirty so
she feels like wanted or should I just
be should I just go [ __ ] like you
know just come with the pimp vibe like
this place is [ __ ] spotless alright
so you need to be on you me need to mind
your P's and Q's whatever the [ __ ] those
letters stand for what does it stand for
somebody's gonna know somebody actually
knows what when you know when you say
mind your P's and Q's there's some
douche listen to this yeah you're a
douche alright that knows what the [ __ ]
that stands for and they've just been
waiting for somebody who [ __ ] it up all
excited so they can be like I know what
it means well send me a goddamn email
and by the way I haven't said the email
for a while here oh what a segue [ __ ]
classic right there I should teach a
[ __ ] podcast class you know
somebody's gonna do that
somebody's gonna teach a podcast class
the same way somebody teach a comedy
class and that's what you do when you're
failing whatever you're failing at what
you do you teach it alright there we go
we just insulted teachers all right the
email is bill at the mmm podcast calm
bill at the capital m capital M capital
P odd cast com bill at the mm podcast
come alright if you don't [ __ ] know
what it by now just hit stop and rewind
on your little player and you'll be fine
I'll buy the bass can you guys I know I
really appreciate all the input and all
that stuff that you guys send to me cuz
God knows if he didn't send it to me I
wouldn't be able to do this podcast see
without you I'm nothing as they slowly
dim the lights and I go into some sort
of pandering [ __ ] song like that
Jackson Browne saw singing about the
roadies like he gives a [ __ ] you know I
think he [ __ ] pissed him off and they
weren't sent his piano upright so he
wrote him a song just so they stop
[ __ ] with them so he can get words of
his tour and then somehow he goes out of
that to just [ __ ] the whole thing is I
hate pandering I don't like and you know
the only know the worst part of
pandering is watching a performer go
onstage and pander to the audience is
watching you [ __ ] animals eat it up
you eat it up every goddamn time we're
gonna tell you something we played a lot
of cities but Hartford you guys you guys
are the best in every way give me a
[ __ ] break there's nothing good about
Hartford you know you don't believe me
ask the Whalers why do you think they
left you couldn't even hold on to the
[ __ ] Whalers how does that make you
feel Hartford still you know why they
left cuz that's stupid-ass song you
sleep what's it called the leap
the brass City Orchestra
speaking of sports I think I think my
good friend Paul verse he's a little
upset with me he's been on this robinson
cano thing I swear to God since I've met
him and he's that you know he's the
classic dude I called it guy and he got
her he called we we actually he's
brought up robinson cano to me so many
[ __ ] times like a year or a year and
a half ago I told him Paul
like I actually put like a gag order
it's like you have to stop bringing this
[ __ ] guy up you're making me hate
this guy and I don't hate him I don't
know what I don't know what he said six
[ __ ] years ago whenever [ __ ] Cano
came up but Paul virzi believes that he
is the only person in America that
realized the potential of Robinson Cano
you know and let's just say for the sake
of [ __ ] argument he does
it's [ __ ] seven years later you know
he's like [ __ ] you don't either and
then and then he's got all these other
calls that that fell on their [ __ ]
faces right you know what he's like but
all he does is bring up this robinson
cano [ __ ] I'm getting sick of it Paul
virzi cuz I know somebody emailed you
this [ __ ] link alright you know what
you like Paul with your predictions you
like Jerome Bettis at the end of his
[ __ ] career where he have 15 rushes
for 22 [ __ ] yards in the fourth
quarter
just totally getting shut down and then
he bust off one for like eight yards 10
yards and then he would get up thumping
his [ __ ] chest like that's what's
bugging me about this where he called me
up this is how [ __ ] sick Paul virzi
is and why you should see him in a
comedy club because you have to see his
sickness life he called me up I'm
sitting on the [ __ ] couch might you
know my name I own [ __ ] business
hanging out with the dog making sure the
place is spotless so when my woman comes
home she knows I can take your [ __ ]
leave you mind your [ __ ] P's and Q's
lady he calls me up and I'm gonna break
his [ __ ] balls about this he called
me up and he goes dude he's like I know
you're not gonna give me credit for this
but this one might be my greatest call
of all he's talking about the Robinson
Cano thing and the way he said this
might be my greatest call about like
he's looking back on this Hall of Fame
career
is the dude I called it guy if I told
you some of the [ __ ] that this [ __ ]
guy threw out there you know dude Matt
Cassel is the real deal telling you the
Chiefs are for real man they're [ __ ]
for real Vince Young [ __ ] Young's the
winner man all he does is win who else I
can't even [ __ ] remember LeBron James
LeBron James he's afraid of the moment
the guy is afraid of the [ __ ] moment
I actually said I don't know [ __ ] about
hoop when he took when LeBron James took
that last-second [ __ ] shot all right
against the Celtics and he missed it and
it went into overtime I forget what
[ __ ] game it was five six or
something like that
what was it was it five no we won Game
five
I can't matter what it was game six or
so no not Game six they kicked the [ __ ]
out of us Game five I think it was he
took the [ __ ] shot and he missed it
far as he goes no way Carmelo Anthony
misses dead no [ __ ] way and I said
dude that was a big moment for him when
it went in or not that was big for him
to get over that hurdle and take that
[ __ ] shot and then meanwhile in the
finals he hits that killer 3-2 [ __ ]
wrap it up then I call him up goin dead
that might have been considering I know
nothing I'll be transmitted the [ __ ]
wall I went to a Utah Jazz Boston
Celtics game and I [ __ ] said call
virzi I'm going through this [ __ ] the
NBA is fixed these [ __ ] guys at one
point you could take somebody's head off
they're not calling [ __ ] and then ten
minutes later you even look at a guy you
got a foul and then it goes back to
taking their [ __ ] heads off no biggie
and it's just like these guys are
dictating the pace they're [ __ ]
shaving points I don't know what's going
on here later [ __ ] mobbed-up ref have
I ever called virzi once about that [ __ ]
and thrown it in his [ __ ] face I
never have Ivan let's do this robinson
cano [ __ ] horseshit and this is the
thing i don't know one person that ever
thought Robin Robinson canó sucked I
remember as a Red Sox fan when this dude
came up all I remember was going like
jesus [ __ ] christ because he went
from Chuck Knoblauch then they went to
[ __ ] Soriano
that was annoying enough because I was
because that point we had one [ __ ] and I
was just going can they can they be
somebody who sucks on this team so then
they trade sorry on if I don't know what
right and then they bring up Robinson
Cano and I was just so [ __ ]
discouraging
that's what Robinson kunos was to me it
was discouraging it's like these [ __ ]
[ __ ] they got they got a guy at
every [ __ ] position and they trade a
guy and then they bring another guy up
and he's the [ __ ] that's how I remember
the guy coming up I don't ever remember
like Cano getting booed and everybody's
saying that he sucked that's what verse
he's trying to claim and evidently he
was the only guy not even the Yankee
scouts saw this guy come this this is
gonna [ __ ] drive him up the goddamn
wall and it's good I'm just trying to
help out his podcast you know what I
mean this is like a reverse you like
when unknown rappers make a mix tape and
they trash somebody bigger than them so
they can move their way up I'm actually
helping him I'm raining down mixtapes on
to his podcast all right now listen to
verse ease podcast and listen to him
[ __ ] trash me alright I think I think
his Chabad cast should be called the
dude I called it podcast I love the guy
I'm just breaking his balls he's [ __ ]
hilarious and he is one of the best
feature acts in the country right now so
if he's opening for some but no kidding
he's he's a he said why can't I
compliment my friends I just can't
[ __ ] do it he's he's a looker
alright let's uh let's plow through here
I just gave him a window that's right
you can't compliment me and you can't
give me credit when everybody [ __ ]
picked something I gave you credit Paul
when you said I got a feelin Tom Brady's
gonna get hurt he blew out his [ __ ]
knee that's your best call this robinson
cano [ __ ] okay
you can stick that a [ __ ] pillow and
you know I don't know and do something
with it go spoon with it cuz I don't
give a [ __ ] you're not getting credit
for it you never will get credit for it
oh by the way did you guys see I know
I'm talking a mile a minute I'm sorry
I'm excited I made a [ __ ] dinner for
myself and it worked
alright I can exist by myself I rubbed
one out today I mean it's just a [ __ ]
self-sustained unity I'm ready for the
goddamn apocalypse my dog needs a bath
look at you each and over there like a
maniac
Oh what the [ __ ] was I just talking
about oh I know I know it's I I know
what I was gonna talk about I I went up
to the the Oakland A's facility this
weekend you know cuz I'm a giver they
called me up and they said hey Bill you
know what we want to give up some root
beer floats
we want to do this to raise awareness
for [ __ ] childhood diabetes and you
know what I did I laughed at everybody
like everybody else going what are you
out of your [ __ ] you get you given
people root beer floats for diabetes you
don't see the irony in that so I got an
email says each season fans and media
ask about the irony of the A's root beer
float day supporting Juvenile Diabetes
Research so here are the facts but when
people ask about it
basically eating too much sugar is not a
cause or a factor of type one juvenile
diabetes if there's any doctors
listening let me know if this is right
type one diabetes also called juvenile
diabetes or insulin dependent diabetes
is a disorder of the body's immune
system in type 1 diabetes the body does
not produce does not produce insulin
insulin is a hormone that is needed to
convert sugar and status' and other food
into energy needed for daily life
scientists do not yet know exactly what
causes type 1 diabetes but they believe
that the autoimmune that autoimmune
genetic and environmental factors are
involved well that pretty much covers
everything people with type 1 diabetes
must inject insulin several times every
day or continually infuse insulin
through a pump eating too much sugar is
not a factor limiting sweets will help
people with type 1 diabetes keep their
blood sugar under control but with the
advice of their doctor or nutritionist
sweets can't fit into their meal plan
just as they would for people without
diabetes so they're basically suggesting
that they can have a cookie - and it's
not a problem
provided they haven't eaten the whole
box like people who don't have diabetes
who do that sometimes evidently said
what they're saying there I don't
[ __ ] know you got to pass this on to
a lawyer or something and there are
times when when sweets are a must if the
blood sugar level drops too low
or juice or soda can be the surest to
raise it and prevent the onset of
hypoglycemia which evidently I guess is
low blood sugar with strict adherence to
a specific diet and exercise plan and
multiple insulin injections each day
based on careful monitoring of blood
sugar levels a person with type 1
diabetes can have some control over his
blood sugar levels so that's what they
say
well let me ask you this the amount of
sugar that is in a [ __ ] root beer
float does anybody need that throughout
the course of the day because I know
that you know some people who have
diabetes will carry around a little
container of like cake frosting and when
this blood sugar goes gets too low like
dangerously low they'll take it out like
a little snifter enough they'll just
take a little frosting right up their
nose and that's a fact you can go to
Wikipedia answer you go to wiki answers
and and look that one up I don't [ __ ]
know I all I can tell you this is I did
a [ __ ] incredible job I'm patting
myself on the back like Paul virzi dude
this might have been the greatest root
beer float ever produced I I got it down
to a science science I got it down to a
[ __ ] science this is how you do it
this is how you do it this is how is
[ __ ] up I was putting the ice cream in
first and then I pour the root beer on
and it would just start foaming up like
I was some sort of a mad scientist I'm
not leaning over to say hello to you
Cleo I'm just leaning over because my
back hurts all right all right beat it
is it weird that I like dog breath you
know not bad dog breath but just in
general it doesn't be don't [ __ ] know
why I freaked my dog out I tell you
every once in a while I just grab her by
both ears and I yell in her face I
[ __ ] love you you know it's weird
it's like I can't believe how much I
love that [ __ ] dog and I have
problems with that emotion so I don't
know how to handle it so I have to
[ __ ] grab her and have her looking at
me like what the [ __ ] you're doing and
then I just yell I [ __ ] love you
right in her face if I told you that
before I don't give a [ __ ] I got a
[ __ ] hour to fill here so anyways
this is how
so the root beer float what you want to
do people is you want to fill your mug
about 40 percent with root beer or
orange soda like a lot of people do I'm
kind of make like a cream sickle out of
it I don't know forty percent and then
take a nice glob of [ __ ] ice cream
and you slam that [ __ ] in there okay
you try to let it slide down the side of
the glass you tilt it like you learned
in bartending school
alright cuz you don't want to splash
because then you're gonna have that foam
[ __ ] problem again you let it slide
this is me this is what I did
people [ __ ] gathering at my [ __ ]
table where was me and this other radio
dude up there named Nicky who was look
like a [ __ ] J Crew model I don't know
why his name was Iggy I forgot to ask
him but all the chicks [ __ ] loved him
and they were looking at me like the
balding redhead that I am you know and
of course like most balding people I'm
trying harder like that short guy out on
the courts got his [ __ ] dick on your
leg playing defense and some [ __ ]
pickup game right one of those guys
that's how I was making these root beer
floats I was [ __ ] killing it so I was
raised so um I [ __ ] I got it down so
I would let that thing slide in slide in
like a ship being set off the [ __ ]
sea you only do that [ __ ] no they don't
slide it down a ramp
no they don't they fill the whole
[ __ ] thing with water
what the hell image is that I don't
[ __ ] know whatever like a [ __ ]
pontoon boat no you know in a snowstorm
I don't I don't have an image for it
whatever let the [ __ ] like quit slid
down into the jaws of that shark in the
end of Jaws except he's not kicking and
screaming he's enjoying it you know like
it like he wants it to happen
no all right whatever so I slide the
[ __ ] ice cream down there's only a
little bit of foam and then what you do
is you put a little more ice cream in
and then you top it off a little bit of
root beer okay then you take a napkin
all right you put it on the outside and
you hand it to him handle [ __ ] first
that's what I was doing that's the way
it went down in case you were wondering
and then I then I I what did I do
oh [ __ ] I went out
and went to an Italian restaurant and
I'm sitting sitting there ordering this
really nice Italian restaurant in San
Francisco and I swear to God I looked
over two tables over and it was [ __ ]
Joe Montana Joe Montana I almost [ __ ]
I almost started shrieking like a girl
Joe Montana is the Michael Jordan of uh
of quarterbacks he just is he's the best
I ever [ __ ] saw there's nobody near
him [ __ ] all these goddamn fantasy
football stats guys I don't give a [ __ ]
Joe got you to the playoffs and when he
got to the playoffs Joe won Joe and
Forno and [ __ ] Super Bowls the
classic story they had down against the
Bengals he's sitting there in the huddle
during the TV timeout right he just said
it's John Candy in the crowd right just
totally [ __ ] hey you know whatever
he's gonna go out throw the ball around
win another [ __ ] Super Bowl right
un-fuckin'-believable so I was freaking
out I actually had a buddy you might ask
me he goes do did you go up to him just
ask for a picture it's like dude he a
[ __ ] mind
it's [ __ ] Joe Montana first of all I
wouldn't interrupt screech if he was
eating and asked him for a goddamn photo
this is [ __ ] Joe Montana Joe [ __ ]
Montana I don't I wouldn't ask if I
[ __ ] I want to ask Joe Montana for a
photo I wouldn't interrupt him for a
photo and I just saved him from [ __ ]
drowning
I wouldn't ask him I wouldn't impose I
would [ __ ] Joe Montana that is that
is the biggest most legendary [ __ ]
athlete I've ever seen he's up there
with I one time I was in Vegas and
Michael Jordan walked through the casino
like late late late at night with like
three security guards flanked at him
wearing one of those NBA on the greatest
basketball players of all time suits
looking like a million bucks they had
that [ __ ] hoop earring they look like
a goddamn I don't know like a [ __ ]
horseshoe just made out of diamonds
hanging out of his ear it was it's just
everybody stopped even degenerate
gamblers everybody just stopped as he
[ __ ] walked by was right up there
with that and I saw
dr. J at the ESPYs last year those my
big three
they gotta be those are the three
biggest guys I ever saw
it's [ __ ] unreal Joe Montana I just
kept looking over at him I said it to my
waiter when he came over I was just like
is that [ __ ] Joe Montana and he was
all geeking out going yeah it is [ __ ]
Joe Montana said I said the f-word like
15 15 you know what is about Joe Montana
fight aside from being the [ __ ] when he
retired he just kind of disappeared
he didn't go on to ESPN he didn't do any
of that [ __ ] on for the first time in
years he's finally doing some national
commercials with that you know hey these
new [ __ ] sneakers they're gonna help
your old feet whatever whatever the [ __ ]
they are is that the worst impression of
a commercial ever
hey the [ __ ] is that Hey look at these
sneakers whatever so I think that adds
to his mystique he kind of left like
Johnny Carson Johnny Carson signed off
that was it he did one Letterman I think
that was it he did one Letterman thing
and then that was it
called in The Tonight Show one time I
think when they were doing celebrity in
a sack or some [ __ ] like that or he made
fun of it I do remember that but he just
left with clash Joe Montana did the same
thing you know he's not out there with
some NBC peacoat right just say no oh
what the George go to do today he's not
doing that Joe doesn't need to sit there
and analyze he knows what's gonna happen
he's [ __ ] Joe Montana I did it I'm
done with you guys guy was still in
phenomenal shape you know that was the
[ __ ] it was the [ __ ] [ __ ] so that was
my week I gave out root beer floats
the Oakland A's Jesus Christ man if you
want to go to a throwback [ __ ]
Stadium you got to go to the Oakland A's
Stadium man and you know what you're
gonna realize how truly fat this country
has gone and I'm not talking about their
fans I'm talking about how small the
corridor is when you walk out to get
food and just the way they used to build
the stadiums the way they used to build
the stadiums you know nowadays you can
order a [ __ ] hot dog you know while
you're rubbing one out taking a piss
still watching the goddamn game you
still have a great it's like sight lines
everywhere
man you just walk in and you're like in
a bunker you have no idea what's going
on there's like a kitchen TV like 30
yards away like like hanging from the
ceiling right that [ __ ] Ken Stabler
donated to it that's basically what
happened and that's what I always
realize when I go to the old stadiums is
how truly fat this country has got you
know I guess they well they was smaller
back then weren't they
they were shorter so as a bunch of
little people just waddle into why the
[ __ ] wood the ceilings be that high I
don't know I was like claustrophobic
walking through the [ __ ] I'm just like
this needs to be at least like another
like [ __ ] ten feet wider it was like
the weather with the Oakland Coliseum
whatever the [ __ ] they call it that is
the antithesis to Yankee Stadium you
guys if you've been to the new Yankee
Stadium it's weird it's like
breathtaking and growing up gaudy all at
the same time sometimes you you you walk
around a corner you see something that's
like Oh Mike it takes you back to like
1929 you think Ruth and Gehrig are come
walking around you're gonna hear their
cleats and then you look to your left
and then there's some guy behind glass
cutting up steaks like you know really
[ __ ] stupid that's what that's what
happens when I went whenever I go to New
Year Anki Stadium I either think about
Lou Gehrig in the old school Yankees or
I think of that Pizza Hut commercial
where that [ __ ] white trash [ __ ] was
eating the pasta going and she did but
she didn't know that it was pizza hut or
dominos or whatever and they were like
what do you think about it she's like oh
my god it's so decadent Pizza Hut pasta
decadent really um speaking of corporate
entities it's time for a [ __ ]
commercial here we go commercial all
right there's only two this week
everybody you know some [ __ ] actually
said you know commercials are only
thirty seconds long on TV why don't you
get on it are they it's enter [ __ ]
containing as these are I don't think
they are sir
and then not only 30 what about those
infomercials maybe I'm doing a little
mini infomercial you ever think about
that you know why don't you just
fast-forward through it you [ __ ]
[ __ ] alright advertisement number one
Amazon Amazon if you have you gonna buy
something online you want to support the
Monday morning podcast this is a great
way to do it and you're also supporting
the the Wounded Warrior Project alright
you go to my podcast bill bird comp you
click on the podcast page and then you
click on the amazon banner this is just
if you're going to Amazon alright just
stop on my podcast go on then once you
go onto amazon.com you don't have to do
anything and then you want to buy
something go ahead and buy it and they
they kick a certain percentage back to
me and then I take 10% of that and I
rounded up to the nearest [ __ ] hundred
and I pass that on to the troops alright
it's a great way to help out my podcast
and great way to support the troops all
in one two and one like that guys
shampoo that it's got the shampoo in the
conditioner right in it right alright
the next one this is it this is the last
one for the week gamefly.com you got
eighteen thousand video games available
do you play video games is that what you
do so what you doing over there
you playing your little video game why
do you go to gamefly.com cuz i know you
don't have 8000 video games i know you
don't gamefly.com does you got 8000
video games they'll mail them right to
your house you can sit there and your
pajamas rubbing your balls as you pay
for them actually you know you have to
pay for them it's a 15-day freed up free
trial okay they'll mail them to you or
send them right to your friggin PC
monthly fees are a fraction of what a
new game cost they got stuff works for
PlayStation Xbox Wii and even on your PC
so for Monday and Monday morning podcast
listeners get a free two disc 15-day
free trial
it's a $23 value by going to WWF lucam
slash burr or you go through the banner
ad on the podcast page at billboard.com
there you go alright that's it wasn't
that painless
wasn't that painless man bitching about
[ __ ] commercials oh you know what I
tweeted about some girl I'm too
old to know who the [ __ ] she is now what
the [ __ ] did I do with all the podcast
[ __ ] I'm the worst I'm hoarse I got all
this [ __ ] here I have you know it's
gonna be the last one that I click on
you know it's gonna be where is it
are you [ __ ] kidding me it's not that
you know at some point I really should
just hit pause shouldn't I you guys you
know what I'm not doing this TV hang on
a second all right I'm back dude I got
to tell you something I hate this this
is a reverse commercial the new MacBook
pearl can suck a dick I [ __ ] hate
this thing
it's not [ __ ] believable I knew how
to use a laptop before I bought this
thing now I don't I don't know what the
[ __ ] is going on I never closed the
window where the [ __ ] did it go dude you
know something that that [ __ ] that's in
your iPhone that's SRI [ __ ] do you know
that like that they sit there and like
gather all the information that you
talked about to that [ __ ] so she can
air-quote help you out better that
iCloud [ __ ] you just given them all the
stuff that you do like did they're a
bunch of [ __ ] creeps over there they
really are an apple a bunch of [ __ ]
voyeuristic [ __ ] weirdos they got
that whole J Edgar Hoover vibe going on
over there every [ __ ] thing you do
like they're peeking in there [ __ ]
nerds they don't know how to get laid so
now what they're doing is they're
standing outside the window of everybody
in this [ __ ] country with a dick in
their hand trying to figure out what the
[ __ ] you're doing how is that legal
why don't they bring it up is this some
legal mumbo-jumbo that I automatically
agreed to the second I [ __ ] bought
this phone I don't talk to that robot
[ __ ] at all I cut her out of my life
you know that [ __ ] John Malkovich
just giggling like a little goddamn
schoolgirl having a just having a great
[ __ ] time with noise the hell out of
me
alright upcoming shows I'm gonna be in
the Inland Empire Ontario California
June 29th 30th and July 1st
with Cleveland Ohio zone Jason lawhead
and Kevin shake Kevin Shay's gonna be
out there good meet the Hampton Beach
ballroom casino July 14th in the Newport
yawning festival Center or whatever the
[ __ ] it is July 15th and I'll be at
Caroline's in New York City from July
26th through the 29th and I will be
making a beeline to the opening Anthony
program to to defend my honor
after Joe DeRosa mercilessly evidently
trashed me last Friday on the show okay
now I know that I shouldn't get mad at
him this isn't Joe this is his addiction
all right the sensation he had he had a
nice run you know his album sales
started falling off he ki got he got the
sickness all right he he was exhausted
he went away and now he's coming back
and he's lashing out at the people that
helped him out in this business okay
[ __ ] Joe DeRosa taking swings at me
while I'm still sleeping taking [ __ ]
potshots at me while I'm [ __ ] trying
to get my goddamn beauty sleep you know
isn't that exactly what you'd expect
from a shoulderless half Egyptian
[ __ ] son of a [ __ ] like Joe DeRosa
[ __ ] he's goddamn [ __ ]
um all right let's let's get what the
question here obsessed friend or as I
read it the first time Oh beast friend
obsessed friend hey Bill first and
foremost like your podcast thank you I
wanted to get your opinion on something
one of my male friends do you have
female friends I don't I don't get how
that works I really don't get how that
works I had such a funny conversation
Wow Jesus was like giggling I had this
conversation with this guy one time and
we were talking about guys like women
who have guys friends straight guy
friends and we were both saying that we
didn't like it like I don't like Mia to
have guy friends I don't I don't like it
I don't like these guys [ __ ] hanging
around and this guy summed it up
perfectly he goes two types of guys hang
out our friends with women gay guys and
guys trying to [ __ ] that woman
and exactly it he put it a little more
colorful in that all right but that's
exactly how I feel you know I don't have
any female friends I have I have a few
but it's like that fight scene with
comedy clubs that's it
we don't [ __ ] hang out though you
know like oh oh you know let's I'll come
by pick you up let's go to the movies if
I'm doing that with you I'm trying to
[ __ ] you you know there's no like what
am i I sit around talking about reality
TVs or whatever can I be more
condescending the females whatever the
[ __ ] it is you guys talk about um
anyways sometimes guys I think have
female friends so they can [ __ ] their
friends I don't know I've never I've
never been able to do that I just like
it's on the tape this is you you know
why I'm here alright I'm not here to
[ __ ] borrow and bracelet you know do
you know those guys are the guys that
get the most goddamn ass other than just
those [ __ ] type-a [ __ ] well just
they just got that thing that makes
girls fall all over themselves I'm not
talking about those guys who just you
know at 13 they get bang a 28 year old
hottie I'm not talking about those
[ __ ] guys you know grow a [ __ ]
mustache already you know those guys
like banging a teacher and [ __ ] and it's
like no big deal to him I'm not talking
about them I'm just talking like regular
[ __ ] dudes who have to figure out a
way to to to to get some those [ __ ]
dudes who are straight and they do that
in drogyn estanque where they start
borrowing chicks clothes or chicks like
they're klitz [ __ ] over it's over you
know when you got a little Steven Tyler
in your tank you know
anyways what am I trying to say here
yeah you weren't like scarves and fire
you accessorize as you dress it you know
there's something about it oh my god I
love that what is that is that maze what
is maze is maze what corn is made out of
them try I was trying to think what is
that light blue [ __ ] that they have in
New
go teal well what the [ __ ] do you call
it Aztec Arapahoe sorry we annihilated
you here's a casino what the [ __ ] is
that [ __ ] called Oh goddamnit who gives
a [ __ ] um white guy pretending to be a
cowboy what the [ __ ] is that pretending
you have a ranch umm this anyways where
the [ __ ] was that one of my male friends
who I've been friends with for a long
time maybe this is the check right there
who knows met this girl about a year ago
and she has since become good friends
with my entire group of friends this
friend this friend has become obsessed
okay the first person you're talking
about now that's what I'm going I'm this
that's how I'm reading this your friend
has become obsessed with this girl and
makes it unintentionally obvious to the
world that he would do anything to be
with her he makes every possible attempt
he can to be around her to do stuff for
her and even helps her pay your bills
well I can tell you one thing this dude
is never [ __ ] this girl what kind of
[ __ ] approaches that you know that's
like giving away merchandise and then
been oh by the way that was 50 bucks
they're honoring the car driving away
alright what you got to do is hold that
do you know like people this is how this
is how you bang a girl like this do you
know you ever watch your hockey fight
they don't stand face to face anymore
what they do is they stand sideways grab
a Jersey and they [ __ ] the [ __ ] hand
back right and they stand in sideways
you know and you got that close shoulder
so that guy can't really get you with
anything if you're doing it right and
then if he goes to throw the [ __ ]
overhand right you're out of his range
unless he's [ __ ] really tall
I'm just saying generally speaking
that's how you do it with this girl okay
you get your hand on her [ __ ]
shoulder and then everything she wants
you hold it away from her so she can't
get it and it's in between what she
wants and her what's in between it is
you when you dick okay that's right
that's how you got to do it that's
called the car sill oh I hope that makes
sense anyways and he'll do anything he's
paying our [ __ ] bills the annoying
part is
he will not be straight up with any of
us friends and say oh he truly wants to
be with her he will only say she's hot
uh yeah I can tell you who's banging
this girl the guy who's not doing all
that [ __ ] um anyways she is aware about
how he feels in an attempt to steer him
away she says stuff like you're like my
brother and will not do anything to make
him think that he's even the slightest
has the slightest chance of anything
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that all right
oh but she'll accept him paying her
bills she's using the guy now this guy's
a jackass
this guy is jackass okay he is setting
himself up to be [ __ ] used okay oh
you're like a boyfriend that's what I
mean you're like a brother she's saying
that right after he pays her [ __ ]
bills I bet she doesn't say that before
you know I don't know IIIi think this is
this is obviously his fault he's putting
himself in this situation but she's kind
of a douche for for using him like that
I I that really [ __ ] annoys me
that that really says something about
this other person do you I would never
[ __ ] do that to somebody
lead somebody on like that why would you
do that cuz you are kind of leaving one
in a little bit oh wait I've taken
advantage of this stupid [ __ ] puppy
love that they have for you you know if
somebody comes up to you and they're
really into you and you're not into them
you know it's kind of your job to stay
the [ __ ] away from them so they forget
about you that that's the gentleman
thing to do you know if they give you a
gift you just take it and you go hey you
see that and you [ __ ] throw it across
the parking lot all right just get it
over with rip the band-aid off you just
be mean to him something you can get him
the [ __ ] away from you all right but you
don't keep being nice to him keep
hanging around him and [ __ ] letting
them pay your bill I guess you guys have
the same group of friends but you know
she should just be like look stop paying
my [ __ ] bills but at some point I
feel like you feel you're gonna feel
like you can [ __ ] me and that ain't
happening
alright so get that egg get that stupid
[ __ ] look off your face it ain't
happening I don't like you [ __ ]
off okay see you at the Reunion she
sometimes even cracks jokes when he's
not around about his never-ending
attempts to win her over
this girl is a [ __ ] [ __ ] it's getting
to the point where it's pitiful and I
want to tell him to stop being such a
[ __ ] and realize it isn't going to
happen and move on at the same time he's
a good friend and I want to be
respectful and I get it she's a cool
chick and she's hot and he's trying to
get it get it in what what would you
recommend sit back and continue watching
the desperation I'll be straight up and
try and talk some sense into him ah this
is always a hard [ __ ] thing because
you could be like you know [ __ ] her
she's using you or whatever they ain't
gonna happen and then they end up
together and then you're the douche and
you get froze out but I think in this
case this kid doesn't have a prayer he's
just he's not even a man to her at this
point he's just showing that he's dumb
that he can be used and that he's not
gonna not nearly make as much an hour as
he should because he's a jackass that's
that's what he's showing her so yeah
she's just you know it's a very least
critique the guys approach be look look
you want to [ __ ] this girl just you know
just ignore her don't ignore just look
hey what's going on just be your [ __ ]
self like talk to other people you know
go hit on some other [ __ ] hot girl in
front of him some [ __ ] like that I've
said this [ __ ] before that's what you do
you know go out start working out you
know take care of yourself get a little
[ __ ] spring in your step and off so
what the [ __ ] he doing all of a sudden
he's not paying attention to me and
that's gonna tap into her oh my god am I
not hot anymore that that fear they have
that I fear that all [ __ ] hot chicks
have the day they're not gonna be hot
anymore you know when they stayed out
there too long you know you got to tap
it in that [ __ ] but then you you're
playing a [ __ ] game you know this
dissed douchebag he sees me [ __ ]
loves you what an [ __ ]
you know what
you say to him one night just be like
dude how long are you gonna [ __ ]
chase this chick why are you paying your
bills you set yourself up like a [ __ ]
SAP do you want to bang this girl stop
treating her like she's [ __ ] Mother
Teresa that's disgusting that's the
wrong one turn up treating her like
she's [ __ ] Mary the Virgin [ __ ]
Mary who has a kid give me a break
right Oh would I [ __ ] give her a [ __ ]
if I ever saw her if I ever came walking
down the street my sandals in my row
back in the day and I self the Virgin
Mary Lee how did it happen
huh how did it happen how did it really
you just woke up and you were pregnant
well congratulations Mary you got
roofied
all right don't take a shower go down
and get yourself [ __ ] swab then let's
figure out who did it Wow ahh let's
regroup from that one all right you know
that that isn't my fault that's some
[ __ ] she that's that's cuz he says
this goddamn question all right what you
don't dude if you want to tell him just
[ __ ] tell him he's telling me that
was a friend I can't sit here watching
you keep running up trying to kick the
football and watch him to take it away
okay
she doesn't [ __ ] respect you don't
say that don't say anything that the
girl said because then he's gonna say it
to her and then she's gonna give you
that [ __ ] you know that look that
girls do when they're mad where they
make their eyes like really small you
know sometimes they have their mouth
hanging open when they do like you know
you don't you don't want to deal with
that did I even give you advice I don't
remember all right should I kick my
girlfriend's dad's ass hey Bill I'm
gonna be giving advice to a guy about
whether or not he should kick his
neighbor's ass well I'm in a similar
situation only involves my girlfriend's
father I'm 22 years old and I am a first
lieutenant in the US Army and I live in
Colorado oh Jesus
he up there in Greeley at Fort whatever
with the bad smell day huh could you
stop slaughtering cows we can't breathe
or they steer I don't know I've been
with my girl for a little under a year
now and her father has not been a
problem up until now
parents are extremely religious oh no
don't play this podcast especially that
last part and they are always trying to
get me and my girl to go to Mass with
them when I first met her when I first
met her dad he seemed like a good [ __ ] a
good [ __ ] this guy's eastcoast seem like
a good [ __ ] kid
we are both gun nuts so the entire time
I was around him we talked about guns no
conflicts at all the second time I saw
him I was in my my uniform and while we
were talking about whatever inane [ __ ]
we were talking about he slipped into
the conversation you know just because
you're in the army you know just because
you are in the army does not scare me at
all oh wow yeah that is weird just cuz
you're in the army that doesn't scare me
at all
I raised an eyebrow at this but I let it
slide I hope you filed that in the back
of your head that's a weird one this is
about eight months ago fast forward to
about two days ago
I'm currently moving out of the military
housing in Fort Carson here in Colorado
spring and I'm fixing to move up to
Denver people are buying the house from
we're still moving out so I had to stay
at a friend's house and my girl was
staying at her parents house
one night we went out to dinner and we
stayed out till around 11:00 and made
out after we ate okay people this is
what I'm talking about where I don't
need to every [ __ ] detail let's just
get to the point here um I made no
effort to [ __ ] this girl because I know
her parents will start foaming at the
mouth if I do but looks like I don't
have to she fell asleep in my car on the
way back so I had to carry her I was
doing so well reading wasn't I she fell
asleep in the car on the way back so I
had to carry her to her inside okay
inside the house is that we trying to
say when her mom opened the door she
looked extremely nervous and my girl's
dad was sitting in a chair just staring
at me as they walked in and took the
girl to the guest room dude why didn't
you just [ __ ] wake her up when I went
back downstairs her dad was waiting for
me at the door before I could leave he
put he put his hand in front of me and
said I want a word with you outside
this is never good whenever says I want
a word with you outside um we both went
outside he outright asked me did you
[ __ ] my daughter I told him no but he
replied you're a goddamn liar
no one stays out that long without
[ __ ] oh my god was he wearing a
wife-beater with his old man chest
sagging a little bit I reassured him I
did not [ __ ] his daughter and before I
left he looked at me in the eyes with
his nose about touching my's and said if
I find out you ever have sex with my
daughter you don't even want to know
what's gonna happen to you I blankly
stared in him for about 10 seconds and
walked away to my truck and drove away
I'm not living in Denver with my girl
and I'm getting calls every day from her
dad asking what we're doing and what our
plans for the day are yesterday he
called up and asked the same old
stupid-ass question and my girl told him
we were planning to go out and see a
movie yesterday he came over to my house
without his wife since I answered the
door he told me to step outside and he
asked me once again if I [ __ ] his
daughter in almost identical conference
say identical conversation sued but this
time I noticed he had a sidearm on him
dude this is this is okay this is going
beyond my my abilities here buddy when
he's wearing a jack with the shoulder
holster but he's so [ __ ] fat that a
pistol insanely contrast with his round
yoga ball body form he once again said
he told me that I don't want to even
know what will happen if I [ __ ] his
daughter bill I need your advice what
should I do about this prick I'm pretty
sure that this guy has no idea that I
went to Ranger School and I have been
trained to shove a knife and another
man's neck with not a plow write I write
I write do what the [ __ ] this is what
you need I don't know what you need to
do dude this is beyond me okay this this
sounds like the beginning of one of
those murders these murder things I
think you I don't know I don't know what
the [ __ ] to do here don't listen to my
advice here because I'm gonna end up
getting sued this one's too deep you
don't need to kick this guy's ass you
don't need to do anything
dad I think you almost need to go to the
cops does this guy have a license to
carry why the [ __ ] is he sitting there
with a pistol and he keeps having this
open-ended thing dude this is for this
guys [ __ ] nuts man this guy sounds
like he's crazy and I don't know this is
easy for me to say cuz I don't have any
feelings in this thing I would [ __ ]
say you know what you need to go back
and move back home with your parents and
you need to live with them and when your
dad can accept the fact that you're an
adult and you're gonna do what you want
to do give me a call but until then I
don't need some guy coming up to me
making veiled threats with the [ __ ]
sidearm all right I'm not looking to get
shot in the [ __ ] head
and that's the thing dude I know you're
a ranger and that type of thing but the
thing about a gun is that makes
everybody tough okay you can [ __ ]
kill Bruce Lee with the gun so I you
definitely do not want to go you know
Steven Seagal on this [ __ ] like III
don't know this sounds to me like I
would get out of that relationship tell
her to go home and just say listen uh
your dad is not ready for you to be in
an adult relationship and I'm not ready
to die or get shot at or whatever
[ __ ] is he has planned I am gonna
stay here and you know enjoy my life
without fat men coming up to me asking
me what the [ __ ] I'm doing with the
women in my life good luck and God bless
and it's on to Chicago let's win there
that's what the [ __ ] I would do but like
I said I don't don't listen to me on
that one I that is beyond yeah dude
that's that's that's a whole that's
whole other level [ __ ] here yeah it's
guys don't send me and [ __ ] like that
that's that's creepy man that's yeah
that's alright okay let's let's move on
a breakup advice alright let's turn to
break the tension here I'm 27 and just
broke up with my girlfriend of two years
we took a break for about three months
last summer got back together in
September and have been going together
ever since
let's read that again I was too busy
thinking of the other thing I'm 27 just
broke up with my girlfriend of two years
we took a break for about three months
last summer got back together in
September
been together ever since I'm gonna guess
that this you're gonna find out she
[ __ ] somebody in those three months
we've been arguing a lot over the past
two months or so but it's all about
[ __ ] nothing serious just little
nagging things that get us all worked up
and then it turns into a much bigger
fight about how we don't see the same we
don't see the same way on priorities and
key relationship points yeah you guys
you broke up you got lonely you got back
together if this happens this is like
the breakups the tsunami and then this
is the aftershock and it finally for the
second wave one fight a couple weeks ago
actually was because she thought she
left the stove on I said no it's fine
she says well you don't know for sure
and then it escalated from there I
thought that [ __ ] only happens on bad
sitcoms now we've never done anything
bad like cheat or be abusive as far as
you know towards each other at all and
when things are good we're totally in
love we have all the same interests and
enjoy doing things together tremendously
unfortunately it's only around 60% of
the time the other 40% were kind of on
edge with each other so she ended up
breaking up with me about two weeks ago
after a stupid drunk fight when we got
home from the bar at 2:00 a.m. her words
were were just not working now since
then she's been commenting slash liking
my pics and status on social networks
and I am I
when we're at work yeah this girl is she
just she's not ready to just go walk
through the pain by herself so she keeps
doing it like this he goes I even got
drunk late last night phone call then
hang up the other night no you did that
she was she was the one to break it off
to she claims she she missed me like
crazy but she just doesn't know what to
do I said we either cut the [ __ ] and
move forward or stop talking completely
she hasn't replied to me since that last
thing I said I really do love this
chicken imagine imagine us spending a
very long time together at this point
I'm almost positive she feels the same
way as well but should I stop being a
[ __ ] and just move along I'm not sure
if these things can be worked out or we
both adjust our attitudes or if
they really is a more serious problem in
the big picture relationship any
feedback would help um I don't know do
you know what to just take three months
for use [ __ ] itself three three six
months just get away from it don't talk
to her
six eight months if you're still [ __ ]
I don't know I don't know how long you
guys we went out for like two years it's
gonna take like it's gonna take like six
eight months to kind of you know it
sucks if you love somebody it's gonna
take that long just to kind of get it
going again but look dude if you're
gonna marry this chick someday you know
why not go out and bang a bunch of
broads now before you get back together
with her and it's gonna be her call cuz
she [ __ ] broke up with you I always
have the same advice just [ __ ] focus
on yourself you know get in great shape
go out go chat up some [ __ ] girls you
think are out of your league
and who knows you might meet a better
one who knows who the [ __ ] knows but at
this point she's you know III would
definitely you just gonna keep when you
break up with somebody you got to get
away from him or you're just gonna keep
hurting each other and you know I I
don't advise advise going out getting
plastered needing a bunch of [ __ ] food
and becoming a [ __ ] depressed tub of
[ __ ] you know jerking off with King you
know KFC containers around it don't do
that go the other way
all right go the other way I don't know
dude just go do some [ __ ] you couldn't
do when you were [ __ ] with her you
know what I mean go take a road trip go
go to a [ __ ] baseball stadium you
wanted to go to go do some fun dumb [ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do learn
how to ride a motorcycle some [ __ ]
cool guys [ __ ] just go have a good
[ __ ] time do something go to an
all-star game you know go out to Vegas
go to that [ __ ] [ __ ] ranch whatever
the [ __ ] you want to do go do some [ __ ]
like that and then you know if you still
give a [ __ ] about her and you know by
the time the next election then I don't
I don't know what to tell you then then
figure it out from there but at this
point I would stay away from each other
see stop hurting each other alright
convincing my girlfriend to get a dog
all right this is a nice showin hey
Billiam son
I've been living my girlfriend for about
a month plus now and seriously the
greatest relationship I've ever been in
really in a month yeah you [ __ ]
everyday why wouldn't it be awesome
in C I just took all the joy out of that
maybe you found the one I don't know in
order to take this relationship to the
next level I would really like us to get
a Great Dane I'm sorry I just had to
take a look at you let's go you just
moved in for a month and now you want to
get a Great Dane everything's going
great you [ __ ] like rabbits and now
you want to live with a little horse all
right I would really like us to get a
great day from all Great Dane owners I
hear they are the laziest dogs that they
don't require a ton of work in
comparison to terror terriers for
example do but they take up the whole
apartment all right they take a [ __ ] the
size of that [ __ ] aged salami they
have hanging in those [ __ ] Italian
restaurants you know you got to pick it
up with a [ __ ] hefty bag I don't know
teaches home the main reason why I need
her approval is because she'll have to
participate in the working in the work
of taking care of the dog most of my
work involves me being gone for 12 to 14
hours a day at dude are you out of your
mind
well her job is 9:00 to 5:00 how do you
suggest I convince this woman to agree
to get a dog dude don't get a dog that's
not fair to the dog okay you're
basically never there and she works 9:00
to 5:00 yeah you're you're you're not in
a place right now to get a dog dogs need
attention they're pack animals they like
laying around with you all right it's
hard enough from for you to leave for an
eight-hour day that's not fair to the
dog man it's great that you're a dog
lover but uh and also I don't think it's
good for your relationship you just
moved in you just figuring out who does
what you having a good time and then
you're gonna add this [ __ ] thing
that's gonna come in it's probably to be
a puppy it's gonna be [ __ ] all over
the place you know you're gonna kill you
utopia I think it's a bad move dude I
think it's great to get a dog it's a
greatest [ __ ] thing I ever did I love
having a dog but I waited till I had a
schedule you know I know and I was with
the right person and all that type of
[ __ ] and I didn't figure that out a
month
so I don't dude I think that's that
might be throwing a giant [ __ ] wrench
in your situation but let me know how it
works out all right overrated underrated
underrated you guys want to send the
overrated underrated this is something
else that you also send to that that
that email address that I gave you
earlier
underrated taking a punch from your
girlfriend's ex I was out at a bar with
my lady and some other my lady and some
other friends I come back from a bar to
see this guy yelling at her friend so I
mosey on over and make sure nothing's
going down while I'm looking at the
Tigers game on TV he takes his swing at
me and I took it like a champ that's the
end of the story dude you got to write
me back I got to know what happened
overrated bouncers oh here we go
they've grabbed both of us before I
could get a swinging but oh well taking
his punch got my girl to do anything I
wanted that night and it made me look
like a badass when the punch didn't faze
me
ah that's hilarious see that see what
happens see what happens when you get
jealous over a woman you go over you
punch somebody in the face it doesn't
even hurt and then he's banging that
chick in the ass so there's a lesson
right there there's one to grow on
underrated cleaning your car clean that
[ __ ] up there's nothing worse than
getting into a friend's car and having
you having to place your feet between
two months of water two months old of
water bottles and coffee cups absolutely
I recently heard a girl on Ari Shaffir
is pod cast you guys gotta check that
out by the way that's another one of my
favorites ari spelled a RI Shaffir sha
fi our podcasts say there's that girl's
take that as a sign of how clean your
bedroom is I think it's true one of my
buddy's cars look it looks like a
recycling center and his bedroom looks
like it hosted a Motley Crue after-party
except that's not except that's not cool
and there was no cool there was no party
yeah absolutely I [ __ ] can't stay in
a woman with the messy car you know you
get it oh my god I have a cat I'm sorry
and you got cat hair all
over you you know and then you see what
they ate for the last six [ __ ] weeks
it's disgusting
oh and I hate when girls have like
[ __ ] half their wardrobe
it just gets disgusting you know what I
mean and I imagine like a guy's filthy
cars got to be even [ __ ] worse and I
bet that's even more of a turn-off to a
woman just because the way was set up
physically you know I just look at how
my god it's gross disgusting I don't
want to bang her you know they gotta
look at you oh my god this guy's
disgusting he's gonna enter my body all
right
overrated drinking coffee to stay awake
yeah you might wake up a bit but you
function like an [ __ ] and your breath
smells like an ashtray eat an apple and
go for a run oh that's how you wake
yourself up Jesus Christ that's pretty
healthy
all right YouTube video of the week
actually just watched the first 10
minutes of this this is [ __ ] awesome
if you guys want to watch a great
documentary to documentary about
bouncers we'll have this on the the the
mmm podcast page you can click on it
it's actually just called bouncer
documentary part one and you get to see
these guys tell their stories you know
some of them are smart some of them are
meatheads I think they have a nice
balance some guys don't want to get to a
fight some guys are like one guys just
like I did sometimes I just want
somebody to say something just to give
me an excuse he's like [ __ ] squeezing
his fists together sweating and [ __ ]
it's a great one
alright that's the podcast for this week
thank you everybody for listening once
again let me give out that email again
just so you have it cuz I haven't given
it out a long [ __ ] time alright the
it once again if you would like to email
the podcasts and you're overrated
underrated and all that [ __ ] and ask
me advice whatever you want to do it's
bill at the mmm podcast com alright
that's it I hope you guys have a great
weekend look at me getting the podcasts
up on time
alright go [ __ ] yourself
you